uh tom just getting some breaking news
on simone biles
yes we are and confirmation that she
will still
compete this week and who would rule out
her out
winning a medal but it will be the floor
discipline the usa gymnastics team have
just
said we're so excited to confirm that
you will see two u.s
athletes in the balance beam final
tomorrow sunny lee
and simone biles can't wait to watch you
both now of course simone has been
through
such a few moments during these
games really bringing to the fore the
issues of mental health
in sport the pressures that athletes are
under and how they deal
with those pressures and to do what she
does in gymnastics and put her body
right on the line she tries things that
other
gymnasts just do not try and more often
than not pulls them off but she has to
be
really in the zone and ready to do those
and take those risks and she said that
so far in these games she's not been
in that zone but it looks like she will
be on the balance beam
in the olympic games this week and who
knows what will happen
you